[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: Hi, everybody.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Good.
Welcome back to the course.
And so we are now at
lecture 10, and let's see.
What have we been doing?
We've been talking
about undecidability.
So we introduced, last time,
reducibilities and mapping
reducibilities for
proving various problems
are undecidable.
And this time, we're going
to-- and today, we're
going to introduce a
more sophisticated method
for proving undesirability
using reducibilities.
And that's called the
computation history method.
And that's pretty
much what's used
in all of the more serious
cases where people have
proved problems undecidable.
It's pretty much a
widespread method.
Especially it's not an active
area of research these days,
but at times when people were
proving problems undecidable,
this was frequently a
method that was used.
So we'll go over
that today, and we'll
prove a few examples of problems
undecidable using that method.
All right.
So why don't we get started.
So first of all,
most importantly,
you should remember how
we prove problems are
undecidable in the first place.
And that is by showing some
other undecidable problem
that we already know
is undecidable is
reducible to the
problem of interest.
So typically, you
might be reducing
ATM, which is a problem that
we started with and showed
to be undecidable by the
diagonalization method.
Or it might be some other
problem that we've subsequently
shown to be undecidable,
and you take that problem,
and you reduce it to
the problem you're
trying to show undecidable.
OK?
Whoops.
Let me fix that.
OK.
So this is the thing
to keep in mind.
To prove a language
is undecidable,
show that ATM or some other
known undecidable language
is reducible to the
problem B that you
have at hand that you're
trying to show undecidable.
All right.
So we are now going to--
first, I'm going to
start off by remembering
Hilbert's tenth problem,
which we discussed briefly
a few lectures back,
as you may remember.
So that's a problem
where you were
given, say, some polynomial
over several variables,
like 3x squared y minus
15z plus 2xz equals 5.
And you want to
solve that problem.
You want to find a solution
that solves that equation,
but you require
that the solution
involves only integers.
So those are so-called
diophantine problems
because the requirement is that
the solution be in integers.
And Hilbert's problem was
to ask for an algorithm.
Not the language that he
used, but doesn't matter.
Essentially, he asked
for an algorithm
to test whether a polynomial
has a solution in integers,
whether the polynomial equation
has a solution in integers.
And as we now know, that
problem was posed back in 1900,
it took 71 years to find the
solution, but the answer is no.
There is no-- there
is no such algorithm.
We talked about this
when we were discussing
the Church-Turing thesis.
And the method showing
that there is no algorithm
is by a reduction from
ATM to that problem.
So one can use
exactly the method
that we're using today
to prove that problem is
undecidable about polynomials.
The only thing is is
that the reduction,
that single reduction, would
take the entire semester.
And I know that's
in fact correct
because when I was
a graduate student,
there was a woman in
the math department
at Berkeley, where I
studied, and the whole course
was to go through the proof
of Hilbert's tenth problem,
of the solution to Hilbert's
tenth problem, the proof
of the undecidability
of the solution,
of the undecidability of
testing whether a polynomial has
an integral solution.
So the thing is is that involves
some fairly hairy number theory
in order to come up with
the right polynomials
to basically simulate
the Turing machine.
So that's kind of getting
ahead of ourselves.
That's what we're going
to be doing today.
But we're going to-- instead
of looking at that problem
because we don't have a whole
semester to spend on it,
we're going to look
at a toy problem
instead where there's
no number theory,
but it still has the same
basic underlying idea
that was employed
in the solution
to Hilbert's tenth problem.
So that toy problem is called
the post correspondence
problem.
And it's going to have
some other utility for us.
Well, the main reason
we're studying it
is just to illustrate
the method.
So and the method is going
to be, as I have been saying,
is this computation
history method.
OK, so why don't
we-- we'll first
talk about this post
correspondence problem
because that's very
easy to understand,
and then we'll spend a little
time introducing that method.
All right.
So the post correspondence
problem is as follows.
You're given a bunch
of pairs of strings.
So here is one pair, t1 and b1.
And I'm writing
them as dominoes.
I'm calling them
dominoes because I'm
writing one of the strings
on top of the other string.
In fact, I'm using t and
b for top and bottom here.
So this is t1 is
the top string, b1
is the bottom string
in the first domino.
And then in the second domino,
we have two other strings,
a top and a bottom and so on.
So we have these here, this
collection of dominoes,
as sort of the legal dominoes.
And what the goal is, to find
a sequence of those dominoes.
So you want to pick from
these dominoes here.
You're allowed to
repeat dominoes.
So you want to pick a
sequence of those dominoes,
line them up next to
each other, and so
that the string that you get
by reading along the top, all
of the ts together,
is going to be
exactly the same as the string
you get by reading along
all the bottoms.
I'll give you an example.
So here, to write it
down a little bit more
formally, so what
I'm calling a match
is a sequence of these
dominoes, so it's ti1, ti2.
Well, it's i1 is
the first domino,
i2 is the second
domino and so on.
And then what
you're going to have
is all the top strings
concatenated together
is exactly the same as what you
get by concatenating together
all the bottom strings.
So here's an
example, and I think
it'll become clear if you
didn't understand it so far,
but it'll be completely clear
from the example, I hope.
So here is a bunch
of dominoes, four.
And what I want to
know is, is there
some selection of
these dominoes-- again,
you can repeat dominoes.
Otherwise, it would be not
an interesting problem.
So you can repeat these
as many times as you like.
And I want to pick
these dominoes
and line them up so that
what you get by reading along
the top is the same
as what you get
by reading along the bottom.
So first of all, if
you just stare at this
and you're trying
to make a match,
you'll see that there's only
one possible way to start this.
For example, if you started
with the third domino here,
ba over aa, it would
fail immediately
because the b and
the a are different.
And if you use the second
domino as your starting point,
that would fail to match as well
because aa would have to be--
the top string
would start with aa,
the bottom string
would start with ab,
and they could never be equal.
So by looking at
this, you can see
that the only possible
choice that you have
is to start with
the first domino.
So I'm going to start to
build a domino for you
just so you can see it.
So here's the match so
you can see the process.
So the match starts with
the very first domino.
And the way I'm
going to write it
is I'm going to take the
dominoes and kind of skew them
so that you can see how the
top and bottom strings are
lining up.
But they're the same
dominoes, they've just been--
I changed the shape.
So this is the first
domino, ab over aba.
Now, the second
domino in my match,
it's got to start with an
a as the leftmost symbol
on the top string.
So that would rule out
this one, for example.
But there might be
several choices,
and so it's not exactly obvious
which one you should take.
What I'm going to suggest
is we take this one here.
So we take aa over aba.
You see it. aa over aba.
It's just written--
I'm just skewing it
so that I can line up the a
over a, the b over b, the a
over a and so on.
So I'm starting to build
this concatenation of the top
being equal to the
concatenation of the bottom.
Following me so far, I hope?
So now, what's next?
So I need to have something
where the top string is
going to start with a ba.
Fact, there's only
one choice for that,
so it's clearly going to
have to be this domino is
going to be next.
So it's going to
put a ba up here,
but then it's going to force
an aa down below because that's
what this domino does.
So this ba matches with that.
Now we have the aa to deal with.
So we're going to
reuse this domino
because that's the only
one that starts with an aa.
So we're going to
reuse that one.
Now we have aa and aba.
Now we need something
that starts with aba.
I see two choices.
Could be this one because
this is consistent with--
at least it captures the ab.
We could try putting
this one over here,
but a better choice would be to
use this one because if we use
this one, we finish the match.
And therefore, we have found
what we're looking for.
And this collection of
dominoes here has a match.
Now, it's not always obvious.
Some collections of dominoes
may not have a match.
And so the computational
problem is, is there a match?
And the theorem that
we're going to prove today
is that this problem
is undecidable.
Simple as it is, simple little
combinatorial problem of trying
to put together different tiles
like that to form a match,
there is no algorithm
for solving that problem.
And I think this is kind
of interesting because it's
the first example of
a problem that we have
where the underlying
question does not really
seem to have anything
to do with computation.
You might argue that
ATM being undecidable
is perhaps a little
unsurprising after the fact
because it's a problem
about Turing machines,
so you can imagine
Turing machines are going
to have a tough time answering.
But here's a problem
just about strings.
And we're going to
show it's undecidable.
So just to formulate
this as a language,
I'm going to call
the PCP language,
is the collection of these PCP
problems, PCP instances, which
are just themselves, each one
is a collection of dominoes.
So it's the language of all
collections of these dominoes
where there is a match.
So it's all of the
PCP problems where you
can solve them with a match.
And we're going
to prove that it's
undecidable by showing that
ATM is reducible to that PCP
language.
Now, before we do that,
I'm going to have to--
I'm going to explain to you
what the computation history
method is in the first pla--
that we're going to be using.
So before we do that, here's
our first check-in for the day.
Just to make sure
you're following me
about what this PCP problem
is, I am going to give you
a question to test,
is there a match
with these three dominoes?
So I want you to
think about that.
I mean, the main thing I want
to make sure you understand
is what a match is
in the first place.
This is not a super hard
problem to tell whether or not
there's a match.
OK.
Five seconds.
All ready?
OK.
Closing it out.
So for those of you who
said there is a match,
I want you to exhibit the
match because in fact, there
is no such-- there is no match.
And I mean, you could get--
by fiddling around with it,
I think if you try
to find a match,
you'll pretty quickly see
that you're going to get--
I think what happens is
you kind of get into--
if you try to build a match
with this particular setup,
you're just going to get stuck
sort of repeating yourself.
And one point here that
you may have missed
is that a match has to
be a finite sequence.
So if you were thinking about--
there is a kind of
an infinite match
that you can build with
this set of dominoes,
but that's not allowed.
We're only allowing
finite matches.
And so that means that you might
change your answer as a result,
but too late.
So and one way to
see that you can't
have a match in this
problem is that you're
going to have to start--
neither of these two are
possible starting points,
so this one is going to
be clearly the only chance
that you're going to have as a
match, the first domino here.
But then once you put this
one down, the bottom one,
the bottom string, the bottom
bs that you're going to get,
the bottom string is going to
be longer than the top string.
And then the other two are
going to have the same length.
So you're never going
to have the top be
the same length as the bottom.
The bottom is always going to be
longer no matter how many more
dominoes you lay out.
So there's no chance of
there being a match here.
OK.
So now we're going
to work our way
up to introducing this
computation history method.
And first, let me define
something for a Turing machine
that I'm going to
call a configuration.
Configuration is just a
snapshot of the Turing machine
in the middle of
its computation.
So if you're running
the Turing machine
and you just stop
it at some moment,
it's going to be
in a certain state,
the head is going to be
on a certain position,
and the tape is going to
have a certain contents.
And with that
information, you can then
continue the computation
of the Turing machine.
That's a full set
of the information
that you need about
the Turing machine that
tells you everything
about its computation
at that moment in time.
The state, head position,
and tape contents.
And so that, we're calling
that information together,
state, head position,
tape contents, we're
calling that a configuration.
Fairly basic notion.
I mean, if your program--
if you have something-- if
you have the states of all
the variables and where
the current execution
of the program is at a
moment in time, same idea.
OK.
So in terms of a picture here,
here is the Turing machine.
Imagine it's in state q3.
The head position is in the
sixth position on the tape,
so p would be 6 because
it's in the sixth position,
and the tape contents is going
to be this bunch of as followed
by this bunch of bs.
So I would write
it down like this.
State's in q3, head
position number 6,
this is the contents
of the tape.
Now, what we're going to often
do for convenience in using
this notion in proofs is
that we're going to want
to represent a configuration
as a string in a particular way
that's going to be--
that's going to--
this concept is going
to come up kind of again
and again during the course.
And so it's going
to be handy to have
a particular way of writing down
configurations for doing proofs
about them.
And so the way we're going
to write them down is--
I think it's just maybe--
I can just put it right
up here like this.
We're going to write down
the symbols of the tape.
But what we're
going to do is stick
in the middle of those
symbols the state
of the machine
immediately to the left
of the position that the
machine is currently reading.
So you can imagine the
head here, which is coming.
Imagine the state is kind
of where the head is.
It's pointing at the symbol
immediately to its right.
So this is just another way of
writing down a configuration.
Here's the tape
contents, which I'm
sort of writing formally here.
I'm breaking the tape
contents into two parts,
which I'm calling t1 and t2.
This is the t1
part, the t2 part.
And I'm putting the state
in between t1 and t2
where I have in mind that the
machine's head position is
right at the beginning of t2.
But maybe this picture just says
it all and it's clear enough.
So just keep in
mind that when we're
going to be writing down
configurations of machines,
we're typically going to
write it down this way.
OK, so I think this
is a good moment
to take a-- to take a
moment for questions.
Oh.
I see there's a lot
of questions already.
So one question is,
how does the encoding
differentiate between
the string and the state?
If I'm understanding
you correctly,
I'm going to be assuming that
the symbols that represent
states and the symbols
that appear on the tape
are distinct from one another.
So you can always tell just like
usually the way we write things
down when you have
a state symbol
or whether you
have a tape symbol.
And so in a
configuration, you're
going to have a
bunch of tape symbols
and a single state symbol
represent in the position
where the head is.
Somebody says-- 6 here is
just this is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
We're in head p--
the head is in position six.
That's all I had in
mind for 6, and that's
why that 6 is
appearing over there
because that's the
position of the head.
Good.
All right.
So why don't we continue.
Now, we're all ready to
start defining computation
histories, which themselves
are not very difficult concept.
Computation history for a
Turing machine M on an input w
is just the sequence of
configurations you go through.
When you start the machine
at the beginning with M
on the tape--
with w on the tape,
I'm sorry, and the head
at the beginning in position
one and the state in 20
or whatever the start
state is of the machine.
So that's going to be the
starting configuration here.
And these are the
sequence of configuration
that machines go through--
that the machine goes
through step by step.
Every step of the machine
is getting represented here
until it ends up at an accept.
That's what we mean by
a computation history,
or sometimes we're
going to emphasize that
by calling it an accepting
computation history.
Represent meaning that the
machine has accepted its input,
and these are the
sequence of configurations
that the machine goes through.
That's what I mean by
a computation history.
You know, I'm sure in--
I mean, I think the terminology
changes over the years,
but there's a notion similar
to that for any kind of--
if you're running a
program and you just
want to keep track of how
the variables are changing
as you're in this particular
run of the machine,
and you're writing
them all down,
it's like a log of the
history of the settings
of the internal states of
the machine and variables
and so on.
So this is just all
of the configurations
the machine goes through on
the way to accepting its input.
If the machine does
not accept its input,
there is no computation history.
OK?
So there is no accepting
computation history, at least,
to emphasize that point.
Because that can only occur
obviously if the machine
has accepted its input.
OK.
So just as we had
with configurations,
we're going to want to be
able to write down computation
histories as strings.
And it'll be convenient to have
a particular format for doing
that as well.
And it's kind of
the obvious thing.
We're just going to take the
sequence of configurations
in the computation history and
write them down as a string
where each
configuration is going
to be the string for
that configuration.
I'll show you kind of a
little example in a second.
But just to focus
on the concept here,
we're just going to
write down the string
for this configuration, the
starting configuration and then
the next configuration
and so on until you
get to the accepting
configuration
and separate each
of those strings
by some pound signed letter.
OK?
So here is a computation
history for M on w
where w is the string
w1, w2, dot, dot, wn.
So here is the--
here is the first configuration.
So this part here is
the computation history
encoded as a string.
I'm giving you this extra
side information just
to make it clearer
what's going on there.
So this is the
first configuration,
this is the second
configuration, and so on.
And I'm trying to even give you
a little bit more detail of how
it might look by kind of making
the example a little bit more
concrete.
So let's say that the
Turing machine, when
it's in the starting
state q0, looking
at the very first
symbol of the input
tape in this particular input,
say w1, it goes from q0 to q7
and writes an a on the tape and
moves its head to the right.
So that's why the second
configuration reflects that.
See here, it went from q0 to q7.
Now the head is in
the second position,
so that's why that state
symbol is moved over one.
And the very first position
now has become an a
because the machine has changed
whatever was on that input tape
there in the first
position to an a.
And then the next step,
it goes from q7 reading
a w2, which is where the head
is now, looking at the w2,
and goes to q8, writing a
c, and again moves right.
OK?
So that's why I drew
these in the way I did.
And so you go through a sequence
of those, you get to q accept,
and that's the encoded form
of the computation history.
All right?
I think that's-- is that
all I wanted to say?
Yeah.
So you can feel free to ask
another question if you want.
I'm just going to relaunch this.
Yeah.
Good.
So if we're all together
on configurations,
computation histories,
and how we're
going to be writing
them down as strings,
that's what we've done so far.
No questions, so I'm
going to move on.
All right.
So let me define a new
automaton that we're
going to mainly use as just
to provide an example for us
today.
I'm going to call this a
linearly bounded automaton.
And all it is is
a Turing machine
where the Turing
machine is going to be
restricted in where it can--
the tape is not going
to be infinite anymore.
The tape is just going to be
big enough to hold the input.
So the machine no
longer has the ability
to move into the portion of the
tape to the right of the input
because there is
no tape out there.
It just has the
tape sitting here
that contains the input,
which the tape itself
can vary in size.
However big the input is,
that's how big the tape is.
So the tape adjusts to
the length of the input.
But once you've
started the machine
with some particular input,
that's as big as the tape is.
There's no more.
The reason why it's
called linearly bounded
is because the amount of
memory is a linear function
of the size of the input
because you can effectively
get somewhat more memory by
enlarging the tape alphabet,
but that's going to be
fixed for any given machine,
so that's where the linearly
comes from, if that's helpful.
But if you don't get that,
it's sort of a side remark.
But what's important
to me is that you
understand what I mean
by a Linearly Bounded
Automaton, or an LBA.
It's just like a Turing
machine, but that portion
of the tape that originally
had blanks is just not there.
As the machine tries
to move its head
off the right end of
the input, it just
sticks there just as if
it tried to move its head
off the left end of the input.
Doesn't go anywhere.
So now, we're going to ask
the same kinds of questions
about LBAs that we
ask for other automa.
So the acceptance problem.
If I give you an input
and some particular LBA
and I want to know, does
the LBA accept that input?
Well, and now the question is,
is that the decidable or not?
So at first glance,
you might think,
well, an LBA is like
a Turing machine,
and the ATM problem
is undecidable,
so that might be a
good first guess.
And also, if you try
to simulate them,
if you try to figure out how
you would go about simulating
the machine, if given b and
w, if you actually tried
to simulate the machine
to get the answer,
so you run b on w,
well, of course,
if you run it for a while,
and it eventually halts,
either accepting or rejecting,
then you know the answer
and you're finished.
But this machine
might get into a loop.
You know, nothing to
prevent the machine
from looping on
that finite amount
of-- on that limited
amount of tape that it has.
And then you might
be in trouble.
But in fact, that's not the
case because when you start out
with a limited amount
of tape, if you
run the machine for a long
time and it's not halting,
it's going and going and
going, inevitably, it's
going to have to
repeat, get into exactly
the same configuration that it
did before because there's only
a limited number
of configurations
that the machine has.
And once it repeats
a configuration,
it's going to be repeating
that configuration forever,
and it's going to be in a loop.
So this problem, in
fact, is decidable
because the idea
is if b on w runs
for a very long time and an
amount that you can calculate,
then you know it's
got to be cycling.
More than just looping.
It's got to be repeating itself.
And so therefore, once it
starts repeating itself,
it's going to be going forever.
So and here is the
actual calculation,
which is something I'm sure
you could do on your own,
but just to spell it out.
So if you have an
input of length n
that you're providing to
b, so if w is of length n,
the LBA can only go for
this number of different--
it can only have this number
of different configurations.
The number of states times the
number of head positions, which
is n, the number of head
positions on the tape,
times the number of
different tape contents.
If the tape was
only one long, this
is the-- this is the size
of the tape alphabet.
So if the tape were two long,
the tape had two cells on it,
the number of
possible tape contents
would be the square
of the alphabet.
And if the tape is going
to be n symbols long,
it's going to be the tape
alphabet size to the nth power.
So therefore, if a Turing
machine runs for longer,
it's got to repeat
some configuration,
and it'll never hold.
So the decider is going to be
hopefully clear at this point.
You're given b and w, so this
is the decider for a LBA.
It's going to run b on w
for this number of steps.
If it's accepted by
then, then you accept,
and if it hasn't, if it's
rejected or it's still running,
then you can reject.
And you know, if it's still
running at this point,
it's never going to accept.
All right.
Any questions on this?
OK, let's move on.
All right.
So now, but what's
different now,
or what's perhaps
interesting now
is that even though the
acceptance problem for LBAs
is decidable, the emptiness
problem is undecidable.
And that's where the
computation history
method is going to come in.
So this is where
we're going to be
starting to do something new
in terms of a proof technique.
So we're going to
reduce ATM to ELBA,
the emptiness problem for LBAs.
So given an LBA, does it
accept anything or not?
And this is going to use the
computation history method.
So this will be a
chance to illustrate
that method for the first time.
So the setup initially
is just like before.
We're going to assume
we have a Turing
machine that decides this
ELBA problem that of interest.
And we're going to
use that to construct
Turing machine-deciding
ATM for our contradiction.
OK, so here is S,
supposedly deciding ATM,
and what is it going
to do-- and this
is going to be the tricky part.
S is going to use M
and w to design an LBA.
That LBA is going to be built
with the knowledge of M and w.
In fact, it's going to
have M and w built into it.
So that's why I'm
calling that LBA B of Mw
because it depends on
Mw, as I'll describe.
And what that LBA does,
it takes its input,
let's call it the x,
the input to the LBA,
and examines that input
to see if that input is
an accepting computation
history for M on w.
That'll be just looking
for computation histories
for M on w.
And that's the only thing
it's going to ever accept.
If you feed it something
which is not a computation
history, that sequence
of configurations
for M on w leading to an accept,
if you feed it something else,
the LBA is just
going to reject it.
It only accepts the accepting
computation history for M on w.
And now, if you can
build such a thing,
then you can use that
machine in your emptiness
tester to see if it
accepts any strings at all.
Because the only thing
it could possibly
be accepting is an accepting
computation history.
You don't even know if
there exists one because you
don't know if M accepts w.
So you're going to
build this LBA, which
is looking for accepting
computation histories,
and then see if its
language is empty or not.
If its language is not
empty, the only thing
it could be accepting is
this computation history,
so you know M accepts w.
Whereas if the
language is empty,
you know that there is no
computation history for M on w,
and so M does not accept w.
So that's the whole idea.
The trick is, how do
you build this LBA?
So first, you're going to make
this LBA which tests its input
to see if it's an accepting
computation history for M on w.
And you have to build
this LBA without even
knowing whether there is
a computation history.
It's not like you
can take that string
and just build a
string into the LBA
because you don't even
know if that string exists.
But what you can do is you
can make the LBA follow
the rules of M. It
knows w, and it knows M,
so it can take its input, and
using w and the rules of M,
see if that input is a
computation history for M on w.
And that's what
it's going to do.
So here is this machine
I'm going to construct.
I'll give it to you written
down and with a little bit
more details of its procedure.
But just to kind
of illustrate it,
so here is a proposed
input to B of Mw.
This would be the x here.
This would be an x
that would be accepted.
But anything else that would be
provided would not be accepted.
So this is the sequence of
configurations written down
as a string.
That would be the x that I'm
providing to the B of Mw.
And it's supposed to be checking
this to make sure it's legit.
So on input x, the
way it's going to--
the way it's going
to proceed, it's
going to first check
to see whether x begins
in the right way because this
LBA, it knows M and it knows w.
So the very first thing
is it takes a look
at the first part of the
string up to the pound sign.
If there's no pound
sign, if you're
going to just feed
junk in, it's going
to be easily
identifiable as junk.
So if you're going
to feed something--
so it's going to-- the LBA is
going to take everything up
to the first pound sign and
just confirm that that thing is
the first configuration,
the starting configuration
of M on w, which means it has
to start with the start state,
then here is w.
So just kind of check that.
Then it's going to check
that each one of these guys
follows legally from
the previous one
according to the rules of
M. It's going to first check
that this one is correct,
and then this one leads
to that one, according
to the rules of M,
then this one leads
to that one, according
to the rules of M. All of
that-- the knowledge of M and w
is built in so it can do that.
And then it just follows along,
checking this computation.
It's easy to check that
a computation is correct.
That's all that's
really going on here.
It's going to check that
the computation is correct
until it gets to the
end and then makes sure
that the last configuration
that it's been given as input
is an accepting
configuration, that there's
an accept state in it.
And if everything that passes it
accepts, otherwise, it rejects.
OK?
And the point is
that this is an LBA.
You don't-- oh, wait.
Just kind of jumped
ahead of myself.
You don't need any
additional information.
So how does it actually do this?
So how do you actually
do this on the tape?
So I claimed that the LBA
doesn't need any extra space
to do this--
to do this check.
It's just going to be
zigzagging back and forth here
on the input, checking that the
corresponding symbols match up
except around the
head position where
it gets updated correctly.
And it may need to mark-- it
will need to mark on the tape,
it's allowed to
write on the tape,
just to make sure it keeps
track of where it is.
But this is a very simple--
I mean, I'm not trying to--
if you're not following it,
I'm not trying to alarm you,
but I'm just trying to help
you understand that this is not
a complicated
procedure here to do
this check that the actual
computation that's written down
of the Turing machine is valid.
But we can deal with
the question here.
Oh, good.
Now we got some questions.
Oops.
You can be thinking about--
while I'm thinking about this,
you can think about that
check-in over there.
So here's a good question.
Going from each configuration
to the next configuration,
is it a unique next step?
Well, I'm assuming that
the Turing machine we're
starting with is
deterministic, so there
should be only one way to go.
So the answer to
that question is yes.
This is going to be
a unique string here.
There's really going to be
only one computation history.
Not that it really
matters in a sense,
the answer to that
question, as long as
that accepting
computation history
corresponds to the machine
actually accepting.
Oh boy, we're all over--
we're all over the place here.
OK, are you ready
to end this poll?
All right.
Well, this is where we are.
Everybody who said they'd
rather be in 6.046,
I know who you are.
You're all going to be expelled.
No, I'm joking.
I don't know who you are.
So yeah.
Good.
So we are here at the break,
and I made this poll on purpose
at this moment so we
can spend a little time.
Let me just start
our clock going,
and I can try to help you,
those of you who answered C,
that you're baffled.
I can try to help you
understand what's going on.
Ah.
So this is a good-- this
is a good question here.
OK, well, OK.
Several good questions here.
So somebody asks, why
don't we just test
all possible strings for B?
Remember, if we're
trying to test emptiness
for B's language,
that's the ELBA problem.
Now, why don't we just
try all possible strings?
And that would work
if we had enough time,
but there's infinitely
many strings,
and so that's not going
to be good if we're
trying to be a decider.
So that's why we don't
just try all strings.
But here's this
other question here.
This is a--
OK.
So the question is, how
do we find the input x?
So this is an important
question because we
don't find the input x.
There's no-- the input x, at
least the accepted input x,
would be the accepting
computation history for M on w.
We're never going to find an--
we're never going to find an x.
We're building this LBA.
We're never going
to run that LBA.
We're designing that LBA not
for the purposes of running it.
We're building that LBA only
for the purpose of using the LBA
language emptiness tester.
We're going to build
that LBA and feed it
into the Turing machine R,
which is going to tell us
whether that LBA's
language is empty.
We, ourselves, is never
going to run that machine.
We're never going to
come up with an x.
We're just having-- we are
designing a computation
checker.
And then the emptiness
tester for that
that we assume to exist
for ELBA is going to say,
yes, there is some computation
which this machine accepts,
or no, there is no computation
and that's going to be a
computation for M on w.
And so that's going to tell
us whether or not M accepts w.
So we're never going to
actually be finding an x.
We're never going to
be running that LBA.
We're just feeding, using
that LBA as an input to R.
Does the computation history
method always use LBAs?
No, as you will see
right after the break.
Because the LBAs is just
kind of an easy place to get
started, but we're going to use
the computation history method
and computation histories next
on the post correspondence
problem.
Yes.
The computation
histories and the input x
are always going to be finite.
So that was an
answer to a question
about whether these
histories or the inputs
are going to be finite or not.
So those strings are
always going to be finite,
and the computation history
is going to be finite.
So we are at the end
of our five minutes.
Let me just see if there
was another question I
wanted to answer.
Let's move on.
OK, now coming back to the
undecidability of this post
correspondence problem.
So remember the post
correspon-- this problem,
you're given those dominoes.
You want to know
if there's a match.
Here is a little mini
version of the diagram,
if that helps you remember it.
And we're going to prove that
this language is undecidable.
And so it's undecidable to test
whether you have a match, given
a set of dominoes, whether
a match is possible.
And we're going to
use-- we're going
to reduce ATM to this language
using the computation history
method.
So how in the world are
we going to do that?
First of all, there's a little
detail here I want to mention.
Just don't focus
on this, but I'm
going to assume the
matches always start
with the very first domino
on the list, the very
first domino in the collection.
So there's going to be,
like, a starting domino.
Just going to make my
proof a little simpler
to do it that way, and then you
can fix that assumption later.
And if we have time
at the end, I'll
do that or maybe after
the lecture is over.
If there are questions,
I can show you
how to fix that assumption.
But for now, to
simplify the proof,
we're going to assume that
there was a starting domino,
that the matches
always have to start
with that particular domino.
If you didn't follow
that point, don't worry.
You can just ignore it.
You'll see where
it comes up later.
So now we're going to
reduce ATM to the PCP.
So assuming we have a
machine that decides the PCP,
we're going to use that
to make a machine that
decides the ATM as before.
So here is the Turing machine
S, which is going to decide ATM.
And the way we're going
to do it is like this.
We're given M and w.
We want to know, as
always, does M accept w?
What we're going to do
is we're going to build
an instance of the PCP problem.
So we're going to build
a collection of dominoes
which are going to--
and that collection is going
to be built knowing M and w.
So that's going to affect the
dominoes we're going to create.
So this collection of dominoes
is going to be called P of Mw.
Depends on an M and w.
And finding a match
for this set of ws
is going to force you
to simulate M on w
because the match is going to
correspond to a computation
history for M on w.
So we're going to use--
once we do that, once we build
the set of dominoes where
a match corresponds to
a computation history,
we're going to use R to
determine whether or not
there is a match.
Or in other words,
whether or not
there is a computation
history, which
is whether or not M accepts w.
So if there is a
match, we're going
to accept because
we know M accepts w.
And if there is no
match, we're going
to reject because we
know M does not accept w.
OK.
This is the plan.
I haven't told you
how to do this yet.
I mean, I'm worried about
the significant number of you
who are feeling
confused by the method.
I mean, you guys should
be texting me and the TAs
to try to at least get a
sense of how this is working.
I mean, we're
going to be going--
we're going to be
doing the method again.
It's just going to be a
little more complicated
because we have to also deal
with these dominoes and all
that stuff, and that's
why I presented it
to you the first time in
the setting of the LBAs,
which were, in a sense, the
method comes out perhaps more
simply.
So a match is
going to correspond
to an accepting
computation history.
Sometimes if I don't
use the word accepting,
I'm just being a little sloppy.
Computation history
and accepting
computation history, for us
right now, they're the same.
I mean, later on,
we may actually
talk about rejecting
computation histories,
but let's not get
ourselves confused.
Computation
histories always have
to end with the
machine accepting.
OK.
Somebody's asking, what
does it mean for match
to correspond to a
computation history?
You'll see.
That's going to be
on my next slide.
Oh.
So this is a good question.
Is my step two trying
to use R to determine
whether M accepts w?
Well, yes, but I'm doing that by
testing whether these dominoes
have a match.
Because R decides PCP.
I can only use R to test
whether things have a match.
Someone asks, should
step two be to use R
to determine
whether M accepts w?
Well, in effect,
that's what it's doing,
but it's doing indirectly
through testing
whether this PCP--
whether these
dominoes have a match.
Because those dominoes
are going to force you
to simulate M on w.
OK, I think I'm
repeating myself here,
so let's avoid getting
into a loop on the lecture
and see how we
actually build P of Mw.
So now you understand
what-- you have
to have the plan in your mind.
We are given M and w.
We're trying to make
a set of dominoes
where a match is going to be a
computation history for M on w.
So the string
you're going to get
in that match, the top
string and the bottom string,
which are going to be--
have to match, they're going
to be computation histories--
they're going to be a
computation history of M on w.
So I want to figure out how to
make my dominoes force that.
OK.
So my starting
domino, as I told you,
there's going to be a
special starting domino
in my collection, which is
going to require the match
to start with that domino.
It's going to be this one here.
It's going to have
these two strings in it.
And you can see
already, it's starting
to look like a
computation history.
The dominoes are going
to have that feature.
So it's the pair of
strings, and I've
written it kind of to help you
see what's kind of going on.
It's a pound sign on the top
and the starting configuration
for M on w on the bottom.
And what I'm going
to do for you here
is at the bottom
of the slide, I'm
going to take the dominoes
I've written down so far
and try to be building
a match, and you'll
see how that match is forcing
a simulation of the machine.
So let's take this
as an illustration.
Let's assume the input to M,
so I'm running M on w now.
I'm trying to see,
does M accept w?
w is a string 223.
So the start
configuration for M on w
is q0, that's the
starting state for M,
and then w following it is 223.
That's what is going to appear
on the tape of the Turing
machine to start off.
So this is the start
configuration for M on w,
assuming that I had this
particular input string to w.
And so given the
dominoes that I've
given you so far,
just one, this is how
the match is going to start.
Now, there's going to
be more dominoes coming.
So for every possible
tape symbol and state,
don't get confused
by the language
here, this is the
important thing.
If in the Turing machine--
and I'll just read
this in English to you.
If the Turing machine, when
it's in state q, and the head
is reading an a, it
moves to state R,
writes a b at that point, and
its head moves to the right.
I'm focusing on rightward moving
Turing machine steps right now.
But for every possible
state and tape symbol
and looking at what
happens, I'm going
to have a domino that's going
to capture this information,
and it's going to
be this domino here.
q a on top, b r on the bottom.
So just a string. q a on
the top, b r on the bottom.
So let's see why?
Well, that's sort
of arcane-looking.
Why is that a good
thing to-- why
is that a useful
domino to put in here?
Well, if you take a look,
let's assume my Turing machine,
when it's in state q0,
which is the starting state,
and the head is
reading a 2, which
it will happen to be reading
because the string w starts
with a 2, if it
goes into state q7
and writes a 4 and then moves
right, I'm going to have--
in this domino, I'm
going to have q02
on top and 4q7 on the
bottom because 4 is what I--
right here, that's the
b, and the new state
that I'm going into is q7.
So that's going to be the
domino that I'm going to get.
And here it is.
Here's that domino
appearing in the match.
So it's going to
match up with q02,
which don't get the--
the top string has
to equal the bottom string.
So and this is going to
be the only choice that I
have for extending the match.
So q02 is going to be on the
top when I put that there,
but that's going to force
4Q7 to appear at the bottom
because that's what's going
to be the bottom string
corresponding to
the q02 on the top.
OK?
So if you're looking
down here, this
is the beginning of the second
configuration of the machine.
That's what I want
to be happening.
I want to be--
that match should look
like a computation history.
So this is going to be-- all
possible right moves are going
to be handled in this way,
and it's going to be a similar
process for the left
moves, but let me not--
I'll leave that to
your imagination.
Now, how do I continue
on from there?
What does the rest of this
configuration look like?
Well, that should just be a
copying over of the remaining
symbols that were on the tape
because they don't change.
Things only change
around the head.
The rest of those symbols,
which is the 2 and the 3, those
should just get
copied over here.
So I'm going to have
two additional--
I'm going to have
additional symbols in my--
dominoes in my collection.
So for every tape symbol, I'm
going to have aa be a domino.
So for every tape
symbol a, I'm going
to have aa be a domino
in my collection.
And so that says I can have--
so there's going
to be a 2 2 domino.
So I can match up
this 2 over here,
but that forces me to
put a 2 down over there.
There's also going to
be a 3 3 domino, which
is going to match
up with that 3,
but it's going to force me
to put a 3 down over there.
That's the only way I can extend
this match that I built so far.
I have no choice.
Those are the only dominoes
that I'm going to be given.
And so doing, I'm forcing you to
basically simulate the machine.
Now, what I want
to have happen next
is a pound sign to appear
here, and that will conclude
my second configuration.
So there's going to be a pound
sign pound sign domino as well
because there's a
pound sign here.
It's going to get matched
with the pound sign up top.
Forces a pound sign to
come down on the bottom.
And if you look at the
way we are right now,
we're exactly like where
we were at the beginning
when we had just this
first domino appearing.
But now we're one
configuration later.
So if you understood that,
and I admit that it's--
there's just one idea here.
And once you get the
idea, it's all trivial.
It's all very simple.
But there's just you
have to get that idea.
I'm trying to figure out how to
get that idea into your head.
Once you get the idea, you can
write all this stuff yourself.
So following this description
of how the transition
function of the machine
works and copying
over the symbols from the tape
to the next configuration,
I'm going to be able
to get configuration
after configuration going
until I get to a point
when there's an accept.
And now, from the machine's
perspective, we're done.
The machine has
accepted its input.
This is our computation history.
But is it a match?
Well, up until--
this bottom thing
is the computation history,
but it's not a match
because the top doesn't
equal the bottom.
There's still extra stuff at
the bottom, which the top,
it doesn't have.
So what I'm going
to need to do now
is add some additional kind
of pseudo steps of the machine
where I'm going to allow the
top to catch up to the bottom.
And the way I'm going to
be thinking about that,
and this is not real
for a Turing machine
as much as the Turing
machine is real anyway,
but you're going to imagine I'm
going to add a new kind of move
to the machine which is
going to allow the head
to eat the symbols off
the tape like Pac-Man.
OK?
And the way I'm going to
get that effect, on the top,
if I have any tape
symbol next to a qaccept
on either side on the top, what
I'm going to get you to write
on the bottom is just
qaccept with that tas--
with that tape symbol gone.
And by repeating
that move after move,
the actual tape is
going to be shrinking.
The symbols on
the tape are going
to be going down one
by one, move by move,
until there's nothing left
except just the qaccept
all by itself.
OK?
So I have this sort
of Pac-Man idea.
I'll be eating the
symbols on the tape.
And then finally,
I get to a point
when there's just the
qaccept alone on the tape.
There's no symbols
left to consume.
And then I'm going to
add one last domino here,
which is qaccept
pound pound matching
with just pound, which just
conveniently finishes off
the match.
And so the match is completed.
This is actually a
little detailed here.
I hesitate even to
bring it up because I
think it's the
kind of thing where
if you understand
everything up to this point,
you could fill it in yourself.
But just for
completeness' sake, you
have to deal with the situation
when the head of the Turing
machine might move
into the blank portion
of the tape, which is not
taken into account here.
And the way we get that effect
is by having another domino
here, which allows me to add
blank symbols at the bottom as
needed.
That's just a detail.
I'm more worried
that you understand
the underlying concept.
So here is going
to be a check-in.
I'm trying to remember--
OK.
But so OK.
So what else can we conclude
from this information?
So we know-- at this point, we
know that PCP is undecidable.
That's what we just
finished proving.
What else do we
know, if anything?
Or do we even know that?
Let's see.
My picture is a little
bit covering the check-in,
but it's still readable.
So I mean, this is not an
easy concept to get the idea.
But once you get it, you'll
see it's not that bad.
OK.
Another 15 seconds.
So this portion-- this
question is not really
relying so much on the
computation history method.
It's just relying on the fact
about PCP being undecidable.
OK.
Everybody almost done?
Five seconds.
All right.
So I can see that there is
some level of confusion.
So the reason why
B is correct is
that we know PCP is
undecidable, but we also
know that it's recognizable
because you could
try all possible
ways of combining
dominoes and one after the
next, except if you ever
find a match.
So that might go forever.
But if there is a
match of a possible,
you'll find it eventually.
So PCP is a
recognizable language.
Undecidable.
And so therefore, we
know its complement
has to be unrecognizable
because that's
something we've shown before.
If a language and its complement
are both recognizable,
then it's decidable, but we
know PCP is not decidable,
so both sides can't
be recognizable.
OK.
So let me prove to
you one last theorem
that's going to be useful
for your homework involving
the computation history method.
So you'll have one
last chance to get
the way we're going to
use this, though this one
is going to be a little bit more
similar in spirit to the LBA
version than to the
PCP version, which
has this extra kind
of complication
about coding the computations
of the machine into dominoes.
Here, we're going to operate
with another automaton which
where it's going to be
more straightforward.
But anyway, OK.
Getting ahead of myself.
So if you remember, for
context-free grammars,
we had the ECFG problem,
the emptiness problem.
We showed that was decidable.
So testing whether a
context-free grammar's language
is empty is decidable.
However, testing whether a
context-free grammar's language
is everything, whether
it's equal to sigma star,
that turns out to be--
that turns out to
be undecidable.
OK?
So emptiness testing for
context-free grammars,
decidable.
Sigma star testing, undecidable.
OK.
So we'll show that ATM
is reducible to old PDA
via the computation
history method.
And so assume we
have same patterns.
Assume we have a
decider for all PDA
and make a decider for old t--
decider for ATM.
Here's the ATM decider.
And now, similar to what
we did for the LBA case,
but with a twist.
We're going to make a
pushdown automaton that's
going to check its input
to see whether it's
an accepting computation
history of M on w.
Just like the LBA did, if you
think back to how that worked.
Remember, the LBA
tested its input
to see whether it's an
accepted computation history.
Accepted if it did,
and then we test
the LBA's language for
emptiness to see if there
are any computation histories.
So we're doing the
same kind of thing,
except now, the PDA is
going to test its input
to see whether it's an
accepting computation history,
and if it is, it's
going to reject.
It's going to do the
reverse of what the LBA did.
And that's going to turn
out to be necessary.
But for the moment,
let's just go with it,
and maybe we'll see it in the
proof, why the proof needs
it to be this way.
So this pushdown
automaton is going
to accept its input if
it's not in accepting
computation history for M on w.
Otherwise, it will accept.
So you can think of this
PDA as accepting all junk.
It just doesn't
accept the good stuff,
the accepting
computation history.
OK?
It's accepting all
the things which
fail to be an accepting
computation history.
OK?
And then once we have that,
we test whether R's language
is everything, whether BMw's
language is everything using R.
Because if that PDA's
language is everything,
then we know there could not
be an accepting computation
history because that's the one
thing that gets not accepted.
That's the one thing
that gets rejected.
So if it's accepting
everything, there
is not going to be an
accepting computation history.
So if there is no--
if this is equal to
sigma star, then there
couldn't be an accepting
computation history,
and so we're going to accept.
OK.
So how is this going to work?
So what's different now about
this case from the LBA case
is remember, the LBA got
the computation history
on its input, and
it used its ability
to write on the tape to
check that each configuration
followed the next one.
We don't have the ability to
write on the tape in a pushdown
automaton.
And by the way,
I hope you're all
comfortable with my using
PDAs instead of grammars
because we can interchange
one to the other.
Should have mentioned
that when I did it.
But so the PDA is going
to be using its stack
to compare each configuration
with the next one, OK?
So the way that's going
to happen is it's going
to non-deterministically
take one of these--
so the very first thing
it does is, as before, it
checks to make sure that
the beginning of the input
is the start configuration.
But then once that's--
that's the easy part.
But once we get going with that,
we push each configuration--
well, first of all, we
non-deterministically
choose which
configuration might be
the one that fails where one
fails to go to the next one.
Because those are the ones
we're trying to accept,
when there's a failure.
So we're now determined to
simply look for the place
that there's a failure.
We push that onto the stack,
and then we pop it off the stack
and compare it with
the next configuration.
So that's how we're using
the stack instead of being
able to mark on the input.
Now there's a-- so I'm kind of
going to illustrate that here.
So as we're going to
read this thing here,
I'm going to put
it onto the stack.
So this thing
moves over to here,
and this input here
got put onto the stack.
q0, w1, w1, it's q0, w1, w2.
You see that.
That first configuration is
now sitting on the stack.
Now, as we're going
to pop it off,
we're going to match it with
the second configuration.
Now, if you're
following me, you'll
realize that there's
a difficulty here
because it's coming
out in reverse.
It comes out in the reverse
order that we put it in,
and that's not what
we needed to do.
So what we're going
to do here, and here's
a little sort of a
twist, we're going
to change the way we're
writing down computation
histories by making them--
by writing them-- reversing
the even-numbered ones.
So this one here is going to
be written down in reverse.
And that's perfectly OK.
We can write down
computation histories
in any way we want
to meet our needs.
So we're going to reverse--
we're going to reverse
the alternate ones.
And now, when we
push one, it's going
to come off in the right order
to compare with the next one.
And so that's how
the procedure works.
OK?
We're running a
little short on time.
You need to be able--
let's see.
So let me just go
to a quick recap.
The computation
history method is
useful for showing the
undecidability of problems
when you're testing for
the existence of an object.
Each of those four cases
that we showed today
involved in testing
whether something exists.
So is there an integer
solution to the polynomial?
Is there some string
in the language?
Is there string that's
not in the language?
Or is there a match?
So that's a typical case
when this computation history
method comes up.
And so as a quick review, these
are the things we showed today.
OK, so why don't we--
we're just out of time.
And so I'm going to
let you go, but I
will stick around for another
5 minutes or 10 minutes.
Happy to answer any
questions if you have them,
but that's officially
the end of the lecture.
OK.
So let me try to
get to-- there's
a lot of questions in the chat.
Don't forget, write
to the TAs too.
So if M does not accept w, what
will happen to the computation
history?
So if M does not
accept w, then there
is no computation-- there is no
accepting computation history.
That's the only kind of
competition histories
we're considering.
So if M does not accept w, there
is no accepting computation
history.
There's no computation history.
So I don't know what it
means, what will happen to it.
It just doesn't exist.
So I hope that's helpful.
Don't we need to be able to add
states to the end of the tape?
Hm.
I don't know what that means.
Add states to the
end of the tape.
I don't under-- you'll have
to repeat that one, sorry,
or explain that better.
Ah.
So this is a go-- this is
a very good question here.
Where does the previous
proof fail when
trying to reduce ATM to ECFG?
It's got to fail because
ECFG is decidable.
So that's a very good question.
Maybe we can just go back
to that last slide here.
Because I was running
a little short on time,
I didn't really
focus on why we have
to accept the non-computation
history strings.
Why are we accepting
all the junk strings
and only rejecting
the strings which
are the computation histories?
So we're looking for
strings that fail.
A string could fail
because it starts wrong.
It doesn't have the
start configuration.
Or it maybe doesn't end with
the accepting configuration.
Or maybe one configuration
doesn't lead properly
to the next one.
Any of those cases
are a failure,
and are going to be
a reason to accept.
The reason why we can
do that is because we're
taking advantage of the
pushdowns non-determinism.
We don't know where the
failure might occur,
so we're going to
non-deterministically guess
where that failure occurs.
If we were going
to flip this around
and say let's accept
only the good ones
and reject everything
else, we would
have to test that
each configuration led
to the next one.
So we'd have to check them all.
So if something fails, it
only has to fail in one place,
and then we can accept.
If it's a good computation
history, we have to--
it has to be good everywhere.
And so the pushdown
automaton, really,
if you're going to get
down to the nitty gritty,
the pushdown automaton can check
that this configuration leads
to that configuration pushing on
the stack and then popping it.
But now, by the time
you get to here,
you want to check that this
second configuration leads
to the third one.
You would need to push the
second configuration onto
the stack, but at this point,
you're already after the second
configuration, so we cannot
back up and push the second one
on the stack.
So the pushdown automaton
is not able to check
in the positive sense that you
have a computation history.
It's only able to--
and accept them.
It's only to check
in the negative sense
that you don't have
a computation history
and accept all the
ones that fail.
And that's just because it
only has to fail in one place.
I hope that helps.
So that's why we couldn't flip
this around and make this proof
work for the emptiness
problem and only
have to work for the everything
problem, the all problem.
All right.
OK, so bye-bye everybody, and
I will see you on Tuesday.